FIRST, THE DEMs AND THE PORN
STAR.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE NEWS KEEPS GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER FOR THE
COUNTRY AND THE GUY LEADING IT.
TODAY THE GOVERNMENT REPORTED
THAT JOBLESS CLAIMS FELL IN JUNE
TO THEIR LOWEST LEVEL IN 44
YEARS.
LAYOFFS ARE WAY DOWN.
NEAR A 50 YEAR LOW.
AND 223,000 JOBS WERE ADDED TO
THE ECONOMY IN MAY.
VOTERS ARE FEELING THE
IMPROVEMENT IN THE ECONOMY AND
REWARDING PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
HIGHER APPROVAL RATINGS.
ONE POLL HAS THE PRESIDENT AT
44% ON PAR WITH REAGAN IN 1982
AND WHERE OBAMA WAS IN 2010.
PRETTY GOOD.
AT THE SAME TIME THE PRESIDENT
IS TRYING TO EXPAND HIS BASE
WHICH IS REALLY SMART.
WHILE MAKING GAINS WITH
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, A DREAM OF
TRADITIONAL REPUBLICANS FOR A
LONG TIME, THIS PRESIDENT MIGHT
FIND SOME PROGRESS.
UNEMPLOYMENT AT A RECORD LOW FOR
BLACKS AND NEAR RECORD LOW FOR
HISPANICS.
GREAT NEWS.
HIS ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
REALLY HARD ON PRISON REFORM
WHICH WOULD HAVE A POSITIVE
EFFECT ON AFRICAN-AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
AFTER THAT NUDGE FROM THE
REALITY STAR KIM KARDASHIAN,
DONALD TRUMP COMMUTED THE
SENTENCE OF ALICE JOHNSON.
A MODEL PRISONER SERVING A LIFE
SENTENCE FOR DRUG CONSPIRACY.
SHE OFFERED THESE WORDS TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL BE THE ONE THAT WILL MAKE
YOU SO PROUD.
I HOPE MY LIFE WILL ENCOURAGE
HIM TO DO THIS FOR OTHERS.
>> Laura: PUTTING THE MERITS OF
THIS CASE ASIDE FOR A MOMENT,
THIS IS A REALLY SMART POLITICAL
MOVE BY THE PRESIDENT.
SHARP!
THIS MAY BE SPARKING A
CONVERSATION AMONG BLACK VOTERS
WHO ARE SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
MAYBE MORE WILL GIVE A SECOND
LOOK TO TRUMP AND HIS POLICIES
DESPITE WHAT CERTAIN PROATHLETES
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS ARE
SAYING ABOUT HIM.
WHILE REPUBLICANS MAKE INROADS
WITH NEW VOTERS, WHAT DOES THE
OTHER PARTY DO?
THE PARTY THAT ONCE STOOD FOR
THE WORKING MAN HAS TAKEN A
RADICAL TURN.
FORMER BILL CLINTON POLLSTER
TOLD ME THIS WEEK.
>> THAT'S WHY I AM SO UPSET WITH
THE CURRENT DIRECTION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE PROGRESSIVE LEFT IS PUSHING
THE PARTY FARTHER AND FARTHER,
RE-DISTRIBUTE AND RESIST.
GUARANTEED JOBS AND GUARANTEED
HEALTH CARE BUT NO INDIVIDUAL
EFFICIENTIVE.
>> Laura: HAVING ABANDONED THE
MISSED OF THE COUNTRY, THE
DEMOCRATS PROTECT AND DEFEND
FRINGE CAUSES AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH NO CONSTITUENCY LIKE PORN
STAR STORMY DANIELS.
RUDY GIULIANI A MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM OFFERED
THIS PERSONAL APPRAISAL OF
STORMY DANIELS.
>> I RESPECT ALL HUMAN BEINGS
BUT I DON'T RESPECT A PORN STAR
THE WAY I RESPECT A CAREER WOMAN
OR A WOMAN OF SUBSTANCE OR WHO
HAS GREAT RESPECT FOR HERSELF AS
A WOMAN AND A PERSON AND DOESN'T
SELL HER BODY FOR SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION.
>> Laura: ONE COULD QUIBBLE
WHETHER HE SHOULD HAVE GONE DOWN
THIS ROAD AT ALL, THE MORRELL
INDIGATION INCLUDING FROM THE
LADIES OF THE "VIEW" WAS OVER
THE TOP.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO SAY
WE INTRODUCED STORMY DANIELS ON
THE SHOW.
NO ONE ANYONE SHOULD QUESTION
THIS WOMAN'S CREDIBILITY.
SEX WORK IS WORK.
EKE
EK
IT'S CONSENSUAL.
THE ONLY INDUSTRY WHERE WOMEN
MAKE MORE MONEY THAN MEN.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> WE ALWAYS HAD WOMEN WHO
WORKED AND WORKED ON THE
STREETS.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE PUT THEIR
KIDS THROUGH COLLEGE.
THEY HAD INCREDIBLE LIVES GONE
ON TO DO ALL KINDS OF STUFF.
THE MERE FACT THAT YOU WOULD
MAKE SUCH A BLANKET STATEMENT
ABOUT SOMEONE YOU DON'T KNOW WHO
DOES SOMETHING YOU SEEMINGLY
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT, SEEMS KIND
OF SHOCKING.
>> Laura: [LAUGHING].
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY ABOUT
THAT.
MAN, I AM NOT OFTEN SPEECHLESS.
I AM GLAD THE LEFT FOUND A CAUSE
THEY CAN RALLY TO.
I DON'T REMEMBER THEM STANDING
IN SUPPORT OF ANOTHER SISTER.
MELANIA TRUMP OR IVANKA OR SARAH
SANDERS.
THAT COMEDIAN ATTACKED HER AT
THE WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
DINNER.
WHAT ABOUT THE WOMEN WHO CLAIMED
THEY WERE SEX CRULL
THEY WERE SEX CRUL
THEY WERE SEXUARUL
THEY WERE SEXUALLL
THEY WERE SEXUALLY
THEY WERE SEXUALLY A
THEY WERE SEXUALLY ABU
THEY WERE SEXUALLY ABUSE
THEY WERE SEXUALLY ABUSED
THEY WERE SEXUALLY ABUSED B
THEY WERE SEXUALLY ABUSED BY
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
JENNIFER FLOWERS MADE THIS
CHARGE.
>> HE CAME ON TO ME THAT NIGHT.
I TOLD HIM TO KNOCK IT OFF.
HE PROCEEDED TO CONTINUE TO COME
ON TO ME FOR 3 MONTHS.
IN HINDSIGHT IT WAS DEFINITELY
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
I WOULD LIKE THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
TO RECOGNIZE AND OTHERS WHO CAME
OUT WITH CLAIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT FROM BILL CLINTON.
>> Laura: THE WOMEN ON THE
"VIEW" HAD NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT
THAT.
WHEN CHRIS CUOMO BROACHED THE
TOPIC LAST NIGHT.
HERE'S THE RESPONSE HE GOT.
>> BILL CLINTON, ME TOO.
>> NOT GETTING INTO THAT.
>> BECAUSE?
>> I THINK IT'S IRRELEVANT TO
WHAT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT.
IT'S NICE NEWS BUT DOESN'T HELP
THE CAUSE.
>> Laura: IMAGINE IF A
REPUBLICAN SAID THAT, THEY WOULD
BE RUN OFF TELEVIG.
-- TELEVIG.
THE ONLY WOMAN WORTHY OF THE
NEWS IS A PORN STAR.
THESE WOMEN WERE UNDONE BY HIS
COMMENTS.
>> WHAT A PIG.
I FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT THESE
COMMENTS.
THEY MADE MY BLOOD BOIL.
THIS IS A BAD DAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT IF THIS IS THE PERSON
THE PRESIDENT WANTS SPEAKING TO
HIM.
>> THIS IS A BAD DAY FOR
HUMANITY.
>> Laura: COME ON, GUYS.
IMAGINE IF AFTER 4 YEARS OF
COLLEGE, YOU SLOG TO PUT YOUR
DAUGHTER THROUGH SCHOOL.
AND OUR DAUGHTERS ANNOUNCED SHE
WANTED TO BE A PORN STAR OR A
STRIPPER.
WHAT MOTHER WOULD NOT BE MAKING
A VALUE JUDGMENT ABOUT THAT
VOCATIONAL CHOICE?
OH, GREAT, HONEY.
THAT'S FANTASTIC!
HANGING OFF A STRIPPER POLE IS A
MUCH BETTER CHOICE THAN BUSINESS
SCHOOL.
YAY!
THE SELECTIVE OUTRAGE AND THE
TWISTED MORALITY OF THE LEFT
NEVER FAILS TO AMAZE ME.
THROUGH ALL OF THIS, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE REVEALED
THEMSELVES.
WITH NONETHELESS TO RUN ON, THEY
ARE THE PARTY OF MS-13 NOT
ANIMALS.
TRANSGENDER BATHROOM.
NFL PROTESTS AND LET'S THROW IN
POT AND THE PORN INDUSTRY.
YOU CAN PUT THAT ON A BUMPER